ever since SATA nadela took over
Microsoft in early 2014 Microsoft has
become the king of Acquisitions they
basically buy everything in sight in
every sector you can think of and
they've only gotten more and more risk
on with time Mojang $2.5 billion
LinkedIn $26.2 billion GitHub $7.5
billion xamax $7.5 billion Nuance
Communications $19.7 billion and most
recently Activision Blizzard for $68.7
billion and those are just the most
notable Acquisitions Microsoft has
completed dozens upon dozens of smaller
Acquisitions throughout the same time
period and let's not forget about their
Investments either just last year
Microsoft agreed to invest $10 billion
into open AI as you can see Microsoft
has committed well over 140 billion
dollars into Investments and
Acquisitions over the past decade for
perspective meta has spent roughly $5
billion in Acquisitions throughout the
same time period Google has spent $16
billion Amazon has spent $30 billion and
Apple has only spent $6 billion in other
words Microsoft has nearly spent more on
Acquisitions than all of their peers
combined times two their Investments
alone are literally enough to be a
Fortune 100 company itself clearly a
gutsy move but this has often been
described as being the smart play I mean
it's not like their peers aren't
investing similar amounts of capital
it's just that they don't invest as much
into Acquisitions when maybe they should
be for obvious reasons buying highly
established multi- DEA billion dollar
companies is a lot safer than betting a
hundred billion do on the metaverse but
is it really Microsoft's Acquisitions
have obviously played out in their favor
over the past decade but that was during
an everlasting bull market where
everything Tech related was going up
during downturns however having clear
focus on a few sectors and pinned Point
Precision over your subsidiaries is
critical and Microsoft's massive
Holdings is basically the exact opposite
of that so will Microsoft's acquisition
Galore eventually end up
[Music]
backfiring likely the best example of a
company failing because it was too
bloated is none other than GE if you're
not familiar with the GE they were an
industrial giant that was once the
largest company in the world throughout
much of the 2000s it was created by
Thomas Edison in 1892 and over the next
Century they became involved in
everything under the Sun from
manufacturing kitchen appliances and
household Electronics to building jet
engines and handing out loans and this
Evolution was largely thanks to a man
named Jack Welsh or Neutron Jack Jack
was a shrewd businessman that was
basically the embodiment of all of the
worst parts of capitalism for example he
was the creator of the Infamous Rank and
yank policy this is when you fire the
bottom 10% of your Workforce every
single year in order to consistently
keep everyone on their feet and
progressing but while that might sound
like a decent strategy on paper it
usually just leads to a bunch of
infighting backstabbing and office
politics instead of true forward
progress GE leveraged this strategy for
a full 20 years between 1981 and 2001
this was one of the key strategies that
got them to the top of the Fortune 500
and it wasn't until the 2010s that the
effects of this practice really started
to shine through the reality was that
G's Workforce had just become a soulless
environment where people only looked out
for themselves as such when the company
started falling most of their employees
just jumped ship and the ones that
remained didn't really unite together
making the crash even more painful and
you know why this practice is especially
relevant well Microsoft leverag the same
strategy under Steve balmer's leadership
between 2000 and 20 4 and that was just
the most notable example Steve very much
looked up to Jack rsh and tried to
emulate his management style as much as
possible leading to ominously similar
workforces and problems for example
within the tech World Microsoft has
become somewhat of a dark course ever
since the 2000s they've grown from
hundreds of billions of dollars to
trillions of dollars while scaling their
Workforce from tens of thousands to
hundreds of thousands but despite this
insane growth no one is particularly
excited about microsof soft other than
Steve balber of course but let's just
say he's biased seriously though when
was the last time that people were truly
excited about a Microsoft product their
partnership with chat GPT was likely the
highlight of their last 24 years of
business conversely apple is able to
reintroduce the iPhone 14 with a new
name and Garner 37 million views on
YouTube alone it's the same thing with
even Google and Facebook while these
companies get loads of criticism people
still pay attention to them just
recently threads was able to surpass a
100 million downloads right after launch
with Microsoft on the other hand even
people who are usually in the know often
don't know that they own GitHub or
LinkedIn the only other Tech giant whose
Workforce is similar in nature is Amazon
which is not surprising given that Jeff
Bezos is also a fan of Jack Welsh in
fact Amazon still does Rank and yanking
to this day but anyway the bottom line
is that whether it be consumers
employees or even investors dealings
with Microsoft are largely just
transactional you could say that
Microsoft is basically the definition of
soulless Corporation this has been great
for flying under the radar minimizing
press coverage and yeting regulation but
this also brings into question how well
the company can assemble and unite
during a downturn if GE was anything to
go by it's likely that Microsoft's
employees leadership and investors would
also just bail as soon as things got
tough in fact they they'd probably be
praised by their friends and family and
even the news for seeing their biting on
the wall and jumping ship before it was
too late and to make things worse
soullessness is only the first
similarity between Microsoft and GE if
we look behind the scenes things get
quite
[Music]
unsettling there's hundreds and hundreds
of Articles and case studies out there
about why GE failed but I don't think
any of them are as relevant as the case
study written by Bill Gates himself and
honestly his article is quite unnerving
I feel like you could go through the
entire piece and replace every mention
of GE with Microsoft and it would fit
perfectly for example Gates could have
said Microsoft's fall is not the result
of innovators developing a better Os or
Cloud infrastructure it's also not a
case of outright fraud like Enron it's a
textbook case of mismanagement of an an
overly complex business only a few
people saw it coming I wish I could tell
you that I was one of them but I was
just a surprised as most people that's
why I was eager to read lights out Pride
delusion and the fall of Microsoft Gerta
and man gave me the detailed Insight I
was looking for into the culture
decisions and accounting that eventually
caught up to Microsoft in a gigantic way
as you can see GE didn't fall because of
some sort of monumental event like fraud
or being out innovated or even the 2008
financial crisis instead they slowly
rotted from the inside out something
that no one really spotted until it was
too late but looking back two red flags
regarding G's downfall become apparent
in retrospect starting with how G's
management team always made their
numbers quarter after quarter and year
after year G consistently posted
increasing revenue and profit just like
Microsoft has since Satya took over
growth in itself is not a bad thing but
such consistent growth can often be a
red flag for more nefarious activities
not necessarily illegal activities per
se but activities to ensure growth no
matter the cost GE for example would
often sell assets to friends in order to
boost quarterly profits Bill Gates of
course goes on to claim that Microsoft
would never do anything to artificially
boost profits but I'm not sure that we
can take him at his word last year for
example Microsoft skipped salary
increases despite High inflation due to
quote unquote economic uncertainties now
this would be completely understandable
if Microsoft was at break even or
burning money but Microsoft would
actually go on to post record profits of
$77 billion that same year this means
that the only reason that Microsoft
didn't go through its salary increases
was to make Wall Street happy to meet
the numbers no matter the cost and put
on a success theater despite the
economic headwinds just like GE
Microsoft wants to be the company that
performs no matter the situation when in
reality that's simply not naturally
possible leading to some questionable
choices this brings us into Bill Gates
second to takeaway about GE which again
can largely be applied to Microsoft my
second big takeaway from lights out is
that Microsoft didn't have the right
talent and systems to bundle together a
dizzying array of unrelated businesses
including Cloud infrastructure social
media AI Tech Hardware gaming video
conferencing and consumer software and
manage them well investors bought into
the notion that the company's hands-off
management style was better at managing
things than anyone else and that
Microsoft could produce consistent
profits even in highly Cutthroat markets
and Microsoft successfully persuaded
people that its empathetic leader Saia
could avoid the pitfalls that had
tripped up big conglomerates in the past
in reality Satya often didn't understand
the specifics of the industries they had
to manage and couldn't navigate the
trends in their Industries for example
the authors make the case that VP Phil
Spencer didn't have a good handle on its
huge gaming unit Microsoft gaming which
gambled tens of billions on Acquisitions
sold money losing consoles and wasn't
even close to Nintendo or Sony making
money from Microsoft gaming seemed
shockingly simple to him at first as
they had already done it with Minecraft
but consistently satisfying a wide range
of Gamers was treacherously complex and
deep risks lurked there and were not
always easily spotted in the quarterly
profits and losses one former Microsoft
executive told the authors that Spencer
struggled with basic concepts the
difference between the needs of console
and mobile Gamers for instance which was
fundamental to Leading an operation like
Microsoft gaming this Dynamic was not
confined to Spencer it was rampant
throughout the company's top ranks as a
result the ability of top Executives to
understand what was really going on was
quite limited the only people who could
actually dig down into the numbers and
see what was going on where in finance
and as I mentioned above the finance
people didn't have much incentive to
bring negative news to Satya or Spencer
as you can see the parallels between GE
and Microsoft are stunning which brings
us into the question of what does this
all
[Music]
mean as most of you probably know we've
mainly covered Microsoft from a positive
light over the past year and in the end
that is still the prevailing conclusion
Microsoft is still killing it and though
these shortfalls may eventually catch up
with them it's not exactly the greatest
idea to bet on that because you never
know how long that could take to play
out after all GE was on top for decades
before they crumbled so Microsoft could
easily continue growing for another
decade before crack start to show and in
the investing world the trend is always
your friend until it's not but this does
bring up the question of whether this
sisa Microsoft will eventually fade away
in the past we've seen Microsoft
overcome massive antitrust lawsuits
terrible consumer sentiment and over a
decade of
stagnation but maybe in the end it will
just be Microsoft's own raw weight that
sinks them into the ground of course the
prevailing theory is that given
Microsoft's hands-off management style
their subsidiaries are rather quick and
Nimble in their own right thus making
the entire company quick and nimble but
even if that is the case today and Saia
truly is a superstar will this always be
the case with Microsoft will they always
be one step ahead of the pitfalls of
massive bloater corporations or has
Microsoft just spent 141 billion dollars
on a ticking Time Bomb only time will
tell over the next decade Microsoft will
not only have to step up to the plate in
regards to management but they'll also
have to address the concern of Market
saturation just like all of their Tech
peers check out this video to learn more
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one